tu t'es fait voler ton vélo écouter ma
petite histoire c'était en janvier
dernier qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il
s'est passé qu'un matin je pars pour
emmener ma petite fille à l'école
j'ouvre la porte du locabello je vois
plus de vélo je commence à devenir
dingue
je fais comment moi pour emmener ma
petite à l'école j'ai pris une journée
de travail je suis allé au commissariat
j'ai porté plainte et la dame de la
commissaire elle m'a dit oubliez votre
vélo vous le retrouverez jamais et du
coup j'ai fini par le retrouver sur
leboncoin j'ai été au commissariat où
j'ai porté plainte je suis arrivé en
furie j'ai dit que bah j'avais retrouvé
mon vélo sur leboncoin et tout il
fallait qu'il me prépare une équipe donc
ils m'ont préparé mes petits et j'ai dit
j'ai donné rendez-vous à 16h au mec et
donc tu as récupéré le vélo j'ai
récupéré le vélo donc du coup il dort
dans ma chambre qui est le mec
[Applaudissements]
le voleur il était mineur voilà il est
mineur donc il a fait 48 heures de garde
à vue quand ils l'ont contrôlé il avait
un couteau de 30 cm de cuisine